for today for the house election law
committee I will start off with the per
usual of the Pledge representative
Brandon would check to lead us in the
pledge
okay excellent I hope everybody had a
great weekend for all the religious
holidays that were going on
um
a couple things before we start up on SB
um the there has been a subcommittee
formed to study campaign finance
representative query is the scheduling
member of the de facto chairman of that
committee the committee membership
includes Representatives Ward
Representatives Muirhead Representatives
Lane myself representative and
representative prude home O'Brien so
representative qualey is in charge of
scheduling that it was noticed I think
honestly two weeks ago but at least now
it's on the public record all right and
with that we will open up the public
hearing on how a Senate bill there's one
Senate Bill 156 uh Senator gray it's
good to see you thank you very much I am
James Gray I represent Senate District
Six which starts up on Route 11 in Alton
gilmanson comes down towards Rochester
and uh all the little towns that pretty
much butt up against that uh
Senate Bill uh 156 does a couple of
things uh certainly there was a
different procedure that we had for
people who registered within 30 days
that would sound unconstitutional so
most of the stuff that you see in the
bill is stuff that takes out the things
that we couldn't do anymore
the other things that I'm going to
paraphrase them kind of briefly because
I I am going to try to make most of my
finance earrings today I'll be back with
you when I need to be for introduction
to bills
we're trying to make it easier for
people
in the state both the Attorney General's
office
Etc to check on people who come in
without a identity you know without
anything that proves no driver's license
no whatever and right now the procedure
is that they they're supposed to get
investigated and we do we investigate
them to the best of our ability but
there are things that when I met with
Dick Tracy who is the investigator for
the Attorney General's office the things
that we can do that help him out okay if
we add a voluntary
um
section in the the registration form uh
when they come in with no ID
if they've got a social media account
and that social media account has been
around for four years I'm pretty sure
that I can find them okay and that's big
criteria for Mr Tracy uh if they give me
a social media account other than that
if they give me a telephone number if
they give me all of these things help
the Attorney General's office in doing
the investigations and narrowing this
may be the problem that we're looking
for and not just people who
um have a reason not to uh to be able to
uh to provide an ID so again those are
the things uh we allow in here uh right
now if you are a moderator or really
clerk you can and you know the person
that's coming in you can certify for
them
if if a voter comes in with someone who
is already on the checklist before the
beginning of the day
and has somebody that they'll be able to
verify for at least two of those people
again what we're trying to do is to to
cut down on the people that we are
investigating such that that we're
concentrating on the ones that that
really matter
so there's other things in there I'm
sure you'll have questions on
um if you don't ask them now you can I
think you know my phone number so you
know an email address if thank you Mr
chair okay questions from the committee
uh representative thank you thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
so on page seven under Roman numeral
five it lists
some of the things uh some of the
additional information
that can be used such as phone numbers
email addresses employer information
vehicle license plate number or state of
registration social media account
so I um I didn't realize the Secretary
of State didn't have access to these
things now
so uh what is the
um
state law is very particular on when it
allows us to use databases from other
departments and if you go into the
statute right now we can share
information about a voter and someone
who has a driver's license for the
purposes of uh finding people to be on
juries and there is limited amount of
other information that you can share
last year we had a bill that would allow
them to share the last four digits of
the social security number but the house
didn't like that as much as the Senate
did and we'll probably run that by you
again soon but not today so
uh okay thank you
thank you further questions from the
committee
representative Brennan thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question how does a voter
um voluntarily allow this information to
be collected by the secretary of state
is that something that's on on the
registration form or affidavit form that
indicates that they can volunteer
they're going to they're going to modify
the form to have a block that allows
them to collect it
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative wood
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you know how many
um people show up on Election Day
typically without an ID
um if it's a town election or municipal
election there's very very few
um right now
we had a special election for state
representative in Rochester after the
start of the new procedure for affidavit
voting and there was no one who showed
up to register uh that day in Rochester
the Secretary of State could probably
tell you how many for the town meetings
that have already been held how many you
know fell into the new procedure it's
not many in my time for being on
Election law
you know we do take the pictures and I
have never heard of anyone that came in
and complained that they had duplicate
pictures of an individual in two
different towns that registered on the
same day so that's a good thing too so
again what we're trying to do is if
we're going to spend the money to
investigate the people we want to do it
as efficiently as we can and help the
the inspector out gathering this type of
information
certainly in the inspector's mind it may
be that if you don't provide anyone any
of that information it may be somebody
that he wants to start with and not
finish with and when he's doing the
investigation but that's uh that'll be
up to him
further questions representative wood
follow up follow up please thank you
um
it sounds after reading this this is
going to be voluntary correct
uh if this passes will the
um Secretary of State have the option I
mean he has a name to run that name
across databases to make uh our job
easier
is he going to be able to do that if
this passes or does he need them to
basically give up that right or whatever
if you look at the state law right now
the the Secretary of State doesn't do
any of the investigations that's all
passed to the Attorney General's office
because he he really doesn't have any
Authority in doing any of that that that
I know of if he wants to correct me then
somebody from the office can
further questions
all right well seeing none um Senator
gray I believe we'll see you back at 1
30. Maybe
um I do not have anyone else signed up
to order pink cards uh Ms tantarelli you
want to come on up but fill me out a
pink card when you get up you have one
you can do it after your testimony it's
all right Miss chance Riley we can
just make sure you get it to me it's a
homework assignment
thank you for this opportunity my name
is Liz tentarelli I'm president of the
League of Women Voters of New Hampshire
and I didn't prepare written testimony
on this because my testimony is very
simple it's time to clear up some of the
language of our voting laws and it's
that part of the bill in particular that
I want to address some of this language
is a remainder from sb3 which was
declared unconstitutional in July of
2021 and it's time to get that language
out of there because all it does is
confuse people so I'm just speaking in
support of it from that point of view
and I will fill out my card okay will
you be taking questions are you also
certainly if there are any all right are
there any questions from the committee
representative wood
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question are you comfortable that
they took out what you needed in here I
think so okay
okay thank you that was that was a hard
ball
um any other questions from the
committee all right
um that being said now I definitely
don't have any more pink cards um
representative can you grab me the
sign-in sheet for this
so we can close this committee and hang
out for 15 minutes because apparently I
can't I underestimated people's interest
okay thank you
um what we had um no one no one signed
in that didn't speak so the Bluetooth is
empty uh with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on asp156 uh the
committee will stand in recess until 1
30 when we'll hear SB 157 I'm going to
grab my Republican colleagues for a
quick caucus over here in the office and
if the honorary Vice chairman mirrorhead
field
yeah
so to build
um
foreign
okay it's 1 30 I'm going to reconvene
the house election Law Public hearing
and I'm going to open the Committee
hearing on sb157 I recognize Senator
gray to introduce his bill uh thank you
Mr chair my name is James Gray I
represent Senate District Six which
starts in Alton and Gilmanton comes down
Route 11 to Rochester
uh SB 157
needs to uh to pass to continue the
audits that we are doing right now
um when I was back in the house uh there
was the election uh Integrity commission
or whatever it is down in Washington uh
had two big gripes about New Hampshire
they said that we didn't have Audits and
we weren't using machines that they had
certified well we haven't changed the
machines that we used and they didn't go
back and certify anything that it was
already out there so it was impossible
for us to have a certified machine
and this Vision here was how can we
audit the machines that we have we don't
have pictures of the ballots we can't
distinguish the count in the machine uh
one ballot for another one because of
the ways the machines do it and so we
came up with a procedure where we use a
high speed scanner we run all the
ballots through there compare the
accounts from the election night with
those counts then we actually do a
sample of the ballots because the
machine takes picture the top and the
bottom and records that against the
number that is assigns so that we can
pull a ballot up and then look at what
the actual picture shows us and what was
recorded in the vote it has worked well
in my opinion you've got the audit
reports that you can go look at this
one of the things that the Secretary of
State's office just asked me about was
how about taking out the words accuvote
okay well this procedure was written
just for the accuvote machines if you
take and certify some of these newer
machines and the Machine already scans
the ballots and assigns the serial
number to them you may want to start in
a different place the other thing they
wanted me to make sure that I clarified
is that we're not looking at doing more
than one machine in locality okay that
we're doing just a very few machines and
if you do multiple machines in one town
then you're uh
not going to be as effective as you can
be in this this random uh audit that
that we're doing by selecting the towns
so that the Secretary of State's office
that they want you know word changed
here or there to uh to make sure that
it's clear that we're not trying to do
multiple machines in the town uh that's
fine with me but remember that my vision
and hopefully your vision is that as new
machines are certified that a plan to
audit those machines will be developed
and and implemented at the same time and
I do not anticipate that that be the
same thing that we're doing with the
accuvote machines because I needed a
starting point I needed a place to start
and that was the high-speed scanner
taking the picture of both sides of the
ballot and assigning it a serial number
so that that can happen the only reason
that uh we do two machines in the
primary is so that when we get to the
general election the Secretary of State
can't come to me and say oh gee we don't
have the equipment to do it any longer
you know we got rid of those a while ago
or or any other reason so we work out
our problems in the primary uh we're not
really trying to audit the primary of
trying to make sure that that they've
practiced the procedure that they're
going to use on Election Day or I should
say right after the election to uh to
audit the machines be happy to answer
any question you have questions from the
committee
representative
chairman thank you thank you Senator
gray for taking my question
um
I just was looking at the fiscal
um schedule and I was just wondering why
um
I haven't
looked at the the physical note in a
while I don't
I know that
in a lot of the election law bills that
came out and certainly check with
secretary's office that they did not
include in the fiscal notes the added
people that they would need to do these
various things
so uh
you know as in my other hat and chair of
Senate Finance I told him to make sure
that when they come in and do their
budget presentation in front of us uh
that they tell me about all those little
things that I've done in all these
election law bills uh that they haven't
asked for a person and you know added
together
um you know we they probably do need a
little bit more of Assistance or a
little bit more in their budget but
again I direct you to there since uh
they would have been the ones that
filled out their
follow-up
It's actually an additional question if
you don't mind so when conducting the
audits
um just to clarify are the audits going
to be on all machines in that one
polling location or you're just picking
and choosing which one and that location
and then randomly going to another town
or city if we are going to do
four to six machines in the time limit
that were provided
um
what we want is that secretary of state
will get there around noon time before
any of the ballots are taken out of the
machines make sure that the any ballots
that went through a particular machine
or segregated so that the tape for those
ballots will match the tape running them
through the high-speed machine I hope
that answers your question
it does thank you uh question my mom
thank you Mr chairman um
all of this says about
auditing accuvote ballots and vacuum
boat machines yep
when shouldn't it be something about
saying reading state Secretary of State
approved the machines
I mean we're stuck with this and then
it's going to have to be changed
sometime in the future absolutely
the my again the things that I've talked
about in the Senate is that as they
approve a new machine okay be it
Whatever Manufacturing is that they
should approve an audit plan for that
machine because there can be subtle
differences in one Machine versus
another that will change the way you
want to conduct the audit in the case of
the accuvote machines I don't have a
starting point of a scanned ballot that
I can identify two particular portion of
the database so I needed to do that
scanning to begin with I don't Envision
that happening on a newer machine
follow-up follow-up also number of
machines and I've been doing this a lot
in a long time the problem is is one
machine out of two or three or four
sometimes what happens is when the
machines goes down and they take all
those ballots
and stick them in another machine just
for get a completely accurate account so
couldn't that be a problem
that's certainly you know anything can
be a problem okay
um what we've done in the past is that
if a machine goes down we there's a
decision made whether or not we need to
rescan all the ballots that went through
that machine or to take a different
machine put it in place use the tape
from the first machine and then make a
tape for the second machine again the
Secretary of State you know is going to
have to to to do this on the Fly uh and
make the right decision for the state
thank you
representative Muirhead
thank you Mr chair
um
I I guess in the ideal I'd love to see
an audit regimen that would apply to the
machines where the state's using now and
any machines that the state might use in
the future without having the you know
without having to write new new laws to
accommodate future machines so one
question is do you think it is possible
to write a law describing an audit
regimen that that would apply to any and
all machines that are in use and might
be in use in in the foreseeable future
and related to that
could would you be friendly to an
amendment that would expand the audit
regime to include
um you know Wards or localities that are
hand counted
um there is already a procedure for hand
count talents
um in fact
it is
all of the ballots no matter what if
there is a race that is a state
representative race requires a recount
uh then up to 10 of those towns are hand
counted uh and that is regardless of
whether they're using the accuvote
machines or you know hand counting them
so that that is part of of what we do
already would I put into law or think it
was a friendly Amendment uh putting a
procedure that would go forever I don't
think that the
procedure for auditing new machines
should be in law at all I think it
should be part of the approval process
from the ballot law commission and this
should be specified you know there if
you disagree with me then you know
you're free to do what you want you want
but I believe that that audit because I
don't know the intricacies of the
machine that it is very difficult to do
that and if I have the ballot law
commission already looking at that and
saying well this would be a good way to
audit it I'm willing to accept that
further questions from the committee
president Brennan do you have a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
if
election audits are
important for election Integrity in
building voter confidence in our
elections
um
does a temporary
Bill like this temporary legislation
fulfill that
um need to increase voter confidence and
election and integrity through an audit
process and is it fiscally responsible
to have such a temporary
fix
um to be putting in additional software
and scanning capabilities for this very
limited time since we are very hopeful
that we'll have new machines for 2024.
and
we'll speak to the temporariness of this
right now is that in in this bill
um when it was originally written I had
a lot more audits being done than are
done right now are in the bill right now
my preference would be that there would
be two machines running four audits a
day for the two days and so that there
would be a total of like 16 machines but
that would have had the Secretary of
State go out and buy another scanner
another computer system another whatever
remembering that the contract that we
have with LHS about the machines being
serviceable for relax
pretty much runs out with the next state
election
that there is no guarantee and that is
why we've tested several machines here
during this the spring session with the
town meetings we tested a few last year
all of that and again yes it is going to
be temporary because the accuvote
machines are not going to be in use
after this and
I should say more than likely won't be
in use
but again we have to certify a new
machine or we have to do hand counts if
we're doing hand counts then I'll go
back to the testimony about if there's a
State Rep race that's being recounted
that current law right now says that we
will we will hand count at least uh you
know 10 races higher level races
um you know from those ballots so you
know we are we're miles ahead of where
we used to be when I was sitting you
know in the same seats that you're
sitting now or 10 years ago so we're
getting there and we just need to keep
representative way
thank you Mr chair thank you Senator
gray um for taking my question uh just a
clarification uh on page two it talks
about the odd team she'll scan all the
ballots which we're cast so I'm assuming
that's in one machine all the ballots
that were cast in that individual
machine correct and then you could
ostensibly compare that with the results
from that machine to show the valid or
validate that uh scan image
was consistent between when the voter
first submitted and then this recheck
then down in section 7 on line 10 you
then say a random sample of not less
than four percent of the ballot scan
shall be selected and then images shall
be compared with the voter choices
that's intended to be a hand count at
that point
well
um of that four percent sampling so so
let me go back to the beginning okay
okay
the you notice that in there there is
nothing in there that says you know this
is good and this is bad okay and the
reason that we do it that way is so that
the information will be available to the
uh individual candidates in time for
them to request a recount so if they
believe that that one or two vote
difference that you see between tape 1
and tape two is enough that they want to
recount then they'll go request a
recount in accordance with statute the
way it is okay so now
how do you one of the the big things
that people said is you can't use a
machine to check a machine
okay and there's some mathematicians
that would argue with you because they
they were ready to provide me with all
kinds of stuff but so how do you check
that second machine well if I had that
machine to start with that already
scanned abouts and assigned a serial
number that I could pull up the ballot
and the way the ballot was counted that
is how in the state of Vermont and a few
of the other states that's how they do
their audits is they look at that
scanned image and they look at what was
recorded in their database and say yep
that was read the way it was supposed to
the capability that we have in the
machines that we are using for this
audit can actually go in and tell you
you know how much of the oval was filled
in you know and allow you to pick if you
wanted to you know then we're not
getting into all of that right now if we
want to look at that when we look at a
new machine God love you you know have a
good time
but again what we're trying to do is the
accuvote machines and and have the
voters be able to say yep that voter
that machine was operating properly on
Election Day
follow up yes thank you
um so
um then you'd you'd leave it up to the
Secretary of State's office or to
clarify the guidelines for
implementation of section seven if there
is confusion in their mind about whether
we're talking about one machine in a
polling place or more uh remember that
if the moderator has or if the control
of the ballots has been lost by the time
they get there at noon time or whatever
and it's a place that uses two or more
machines you may be in a condition where
you have to do all of the ballots at
that polling place to regain control
okay but that is not the intent the
intent is to control those ballots make
sure that I only am worried about you
know the ballots that went through a
particular machine at that voting
location and then comparing that tape
with another one again you know if I
always when I when I took statistics in
college I called it sadistics but you
know you can call it what you want but
that you know
the the percentages that we're using are
supposed to give us a a confidence
factor and it's not as high as I would
like it because I would have done more
but I think it's sufficient to to prove
our point
I enjoy statistics representative weary
follow-up yeah uh when my graduate are
you an N or an N plus one guy oh I'm an
M plus one sample so
n plus 1 is a sample instead of N and
we're with a total population when my
grandfather taught statistics they
called it the mystery hour so okay
so uh just uh follow up to that section
seven how is the four percent arrived at
was there any
it was a wild guess you know picked from
a dark place you know uh statistic
statistician's brain possibly so and
we did look at you know n n plus one you
know standard deviations how many you
know and all of that but
when it went through the committee the
last time uh two years ago
um it was easier to say we're going to
pick X number of machines or
and they understood it much better that
way
further questions and I'm sure we'll
enjoy some statistics conversations
later uh thank you uh Senator gray we'll
see you back here in I guess 10 minutes
uh probably not you may be able to spend
a little time in the hallway
um next up is going to be Michael
O'Brien from Auburn representing America
votes and the Brennan Center
uh and uh Mr Brian when you get up here
you got to tell us if you support or
support it all right we'll write that on
your pink card support ish
foreign
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael O'Brien I
am a lobbyist of pretty strategies here
representing America votes and reading
testimony on behalf of Lisa danich from
the Brennan Center I'm passing a
testimony around so I won't read it
verbatim and there are people behind me
who may be able to better answer some
questions but I'll do my best to try
um we want to thank Senator gray for
bringing this bill forward but it's some
questions have indicated I think we're
looking for a sort of longer term
solution to the audits that we think can
be used both for accuvotes and other
machines so just a few of the points
from from Lisa who could not be here
today because I think she's in a place
that's warmer in some year even though
it's pretty nice out today but Italy is
also maybe better food I don't really
know what's going on but
um first and most importantly she
recommends this bill should require a
manual review of some ballots to check
that the ballots were counted accurately
so the point here is that through the
scanner if
um to explain this recommendation I'll
read let me backtrack for a moment and
describe how the proposed audit Works in
step one paper ballots from selected
towns and City Wards are scanned into
the audit device and recounted the
totals from the audit devices compared
with the totals counted during the
election to make sure they match so
that's obviously the first step step two
of the audit is then the process that
ensures the audit device itself works
properly and has not been comprised in
any way in step two there should be a
comparison of a random sample of
auto-day paper ballots with the ballot
interpretations for those recorded by
um because voters ballots provide the
most trustworthy record of Voters
intentions New Hampshire's Auto process
should incorporate use of that
authoritative device so you want to look
at not just a scan ballot but then a
sub-sample of actual ballots to make
sure it's then matching the device that
is scanning them
uh Second and also quite importantly New
Hampshire audits should not be limited
to ballots counted by accuvote devices
this was just discussed instead all the
states battles should be within the
audit scope to assure a broad
representation of New Hampshire voters
this assures that voters of the audit
procedure hasn't been favored or
cherry-picked some places or machines
while avoiding others by making explicit
reference to an audit of the accuvote
electronic ballot accounting devices SB
157 excludes the audit scope
jurisdictions that could use hand counts
and also those that replace their active
volt machines again hopefully sooner
than later third we recommend
modifications related to the selection
of towns and City Wards subject to the
audit there should be an increase in the
number of towns and City Awards selected
to be part of the audit since a graded
number of batches in an audit improves
the accuracy of the audit since we
recommend a comparison of smaller number
of paper ballots so they're recommending
that you compare 100 paper ballots as
opposed to the four percent it should
not increase the workload tremendously
to then add in some more Awards or towns
to choose from fourth we recommend
expanding the legislation to cover
presidential primaries it doesn't
currently do that and if folks have
concern over the accuracy of Elections
it feels like the presidential primary
would be a good place for folks to go so
let's make sure that's covered as well
to make sure folks feel confident in all
of our elections and Fifth and finally
we recommend including within the bill
language regarding a process to file if
an audit uncovers differences in the
count which this bill currently does not
do so those are the recommendations from
Lisa dance who is a member from this
committee is much smarter than I but I
will do my best to try to answer any
questions or leave it to the people
okay questions from the committee
you're getting off easy oh no remember
representative you have a question
just a quick one thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question
um
it's my understanding that the new
ballot counting machines that are being
considered have the scanning
capabilities already built in and would
be able to easily provide scanned images
for an audit
um in the testimony that is provided
here from Lisa Dennis would it also be
her testimony and your testimony that in
if the committee were to reword this uh
make an amendment to this bill
that
we make sure we're really capturing
um
the needs for the future and not just
the temporary with the Accu active vote
yeah so I think that's right I think the
recommendations here I'm from the
Running Center from Lisa are
recommendations that have been best
practices from other states that do
Audits and most other states at this
point do audit and so regardless of
almost no one else who's in the acne
vote machine right so it's not like this
wouldn't apply to some of the newer
machines that exist
um I you know I won't speak to what the
new technologies of the machines can do
especially because that state hasn't
actually chosen one yet and so we're
still in the process and I bet different
things do different ones but I think
it's safe to say the recommendations
that
she brought forward here apply writ
large to you know any machine that the
state might might choose
okay now further questions all right now
you get off easy uh next up is uh deputy
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um I am here representing the Secretary
of State and I wanted to let you know
that we do support this bill
um the audits that we did in 2022 were
very effective
um and and to Senator Gray's point you
can go on our website and read those
reports that we've done uh initially
Senator gray had had more devices that
were to be audited and at a higher
percentage and we had asked him to
reduce that to someone had asked the
where did the numbers come from we'd
asked them to reduce that number on the
Senate side because of timing
we do the audits after the election but
before the deadline to request a recount
so that if the audit turns up anything
where a candidate would question
something they have the um the option of
using that information in their decision
process
um
we are also
as you know looking at different ballot
counting devices and we do a an audit of
those devices every ballot that's gone
through those devices after they've been
used so somebody can also have the
option to request a recount if
information comes out of that so there's
a fine timeline of when
um after an election and before the
recount deadline for us to
actually get audits done and the other
thing to someone else's point had asked
about uh the fiscal note
so we this um
Bill had already been in effect but
sunsetted and for that bill we purchased
about a high span skin high speed
scanner in order to perform that audit
we still have that scanner which is
great but there is an annual maintenance
cost for that scanner of thirty seven
thousand dollars whether you use it or
not and
um and then there is a ballot
programming fee of approximately two
thousand dollars per ballot so that's
why you see a different cost in odd
years versus even years
on the fiscal note
yeah
uh sorry Mr chairman do you have a
question no I'm sorry I'm just appalled
by those numbers
um that's I was I should have poker face
a little better
um
uh to the um Senators
um point of the of the um the number of
devices that we're counting poor per
town or city Ward when we had reviewed
this for our 2022 elections in the
post-election audits that we did we
reviews this reviewed this with the AG's
office and although we knew it was
Senator Gray's intent to just count one
device the wording wasn't clear to us
that we could only just count one device
in a polling location so just to make it
absolutely clear about what the intent
is we would like to add some language to
line 26.
that says and not more than one device
from a town or city Ward
and also to the sponsors point if when
we arrive at noon if something were to
happen to that device that we
um
that we had randomly selected to audit
or if the ballots had been commingled
into a box if say that machine had
gotten full and another machine had
gotten full and they co-mingled those
ballots
um we would then count
um do the audit on any of the commingled
devices so we would expand that out to
whatever devices had been commingled
together the point I believe of the 12
p.m on Election Day is just to not not
give anybody a heads up that they're
going to be audited
um let's see I think that
is all that I have for you today I'm
happy to answer questions okay questions
yes representative weary thank you Mr
uh so for the if you find a problem
what's this Secretary of State's ought
would you expand the audit in if there
was a problem found so you know
traditionally if an audit
is performed in a sample is taken and
you find issues generally audits are
expanded as as there been any thought
along those lines
thank you for the question so if you're
saying if what one device if with one
device we find an issue would we expand
our sample size is that your question
um we have not encountered that
um a lot of the locations only have one
device so so would we expand our sample
size Beyond
a town that we're counting or is your
question more towards if say a large
polling location that has multiple
devices
so I think I think it can actually be
two-fold in that you
if you find that there is a problem in a
particular Ward or town with multiple
devices
um you know is there a systemic problem
in that Locale or conversely is you know
is there a systemic problem in a broader
range for similar devices that are
throughout the state so I think it's
it's really to to both questions because
the handling locally can be different
that may have led to those issues or the
handling or the
if there are if there are broader kind
of larger Regional Statewide issues that
may be a more systemic issue from LHS or
whomever you know whatever system is
handling that so
so thank you I think I think that's
to your Quit Line of questioning I think
that's one of the reasons why we do the
audits is just to show the public that
they can have
um confidence in their elections if we
were to encounter an issue that we could
not easily explain like
the moderator comes to us and say oh you
know what I think
I
did before you got there co-mingle
ballots or something along those lines
um if we cannot come up with an answer
then we would get the Attorney General's
office involved and have to figure it
out from there
um
we love it when the ages office gets
involved representative you have a
question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
going back to the fiscal note and the
cost of the of conducting the audits
using the the specific software that is
the 37 000 per year for the high-speed
scanner software
with the new
ballot counting machines that this
Secretary of State's office and ballot
commission are considering
um
it's my understanding that they have
high-speed scanners within them and
appropriate software for scanning
would
approving those devices and getting
those devices online ASAP reduce the
fiscal impact of the audit as we see
here in this bill or is there an
additional would we be paying an
additional cost for high-speed scan it
scanning audits regardless
thank you for the question
representative I I don't see
unless the population were to change I
don't see the audit price changing
whether you had
um one type of device or two type of
device the the new ballot electronic
ballot accounting devices that are being
looked at do have the scanning
capability but none of the ones that we
are currently looking at
they are not they are not high speed
scanners because we don't have big
Central locations where we high-seed
scan all of our ballots so they're a
little bit different than the actual
scanning machine that we use for our
audits
quick follow-up please yep thank you
um
the new machines they do scan those
images and so
um doing an audit based on those images
scanned would that be less of a cost
than using the high-speed scanners and
be able to speed up the process even
without using the high speed scanners
great question I think depending on what
the
um the rules of the audit are and how
um who writes them and and how they're
written it could possibly be less time
and
um I don't think there'd be
it would not be less expensive because
you would still have to pay for the
software and the reading of the ballot
thank you
representative Bay
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my call
um
because I haven't looked at the website
uh I'd like to ask the high-speed
scanner that you refer to does it
specify in the website the the
manufacturer the model number and all
that kind of information and uh
thank you for the question I believe in
the report it does reference what it is
I don't know if it does the model number
but it is a clear ballot high-speed
scanning device clear ballot is the
manufacturer but I can get you that
information
um thank you uh follow up um this is
also specify the the software
um that's used to uh read the votes and
uh the manufacturer and the or whoever
is the company that publishes the
software
thank you so clear ballot has their own
software and proprietary it's not open
sourced
um all of the devices that we're looking
at all of the
devices that were looking ballot
counting devices we're looking at are
proprietary software except for one
that's an open source software thank you
okay and the deputy secretary is under
time constraints so I'm gonna take one
last question here representative
Burnham
thank you Mr chairman thank you Deputy
Hennessy I was wondering
when the audit is being conducted it
says in the public is that right next to
where the machines are or is this in a
different location open to the public
will they be transferring those ballots
go to another location thank you for the
question so the um when um noon comes
around a person from the Secretary of
State's office is at the polling
location to inform the moderator that
they are been luckily chosen to have an
audit done of their machine and we are
there until the close of polls when they
seal that box so we can see that no
ballots have been commingled the next
morning the Secretary of State's office
comes and picks up those
those boxes are box for that machine and
the town signs them over to us on their
logs they are then transferred to the
archives building Secretary of State's
archives building and the audits are
held at The Archives building I believe
that's where we'll do them in the future
it's worked out very well it's the same
place if you've ever attended a recount
that's where we do our recounts as well
and they are definitely open to the
public
okay thank you secretary I believe you I
believe you are out of time with us so
I'm going to uh say thank you so much
well I think we'll see you later today
maybe
next up is uh Susan paschell from
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Susan paschell from the
DuPont group in Concord and I'm going to
read a statement in support of this bill
on behalf of secure democracy secure
democracy is a nonpartisan non-profit
organization that works to improve
election integrity and ensure all
eligible citizens have the freedom to
vote how they choose from the creation
and printing of the ballots to the
actual programming of the voting machine
the voting process is a human process as
a result human errors can cause mistakes
in the tabulation process
a post-election audit checks that the
voting equipment and procedures used to
count votes function properly and that
the reported election outcome was
correct additionally post-election
audits are recommended by election
Security Experts as a method to protect
election Integrity the 2023 report
issued by the New Hampshire special
committee on voter confidence found that
election audits increased voter
confidence public comment from voters
across the state showed that New
Hampshire should have a robust audit
process this bill is a measured step to
cultivating and implementing an audit
process that will increase voters trust
in the New Hampshire electoral system we
see this as a practical Common Sense
step forward for New Hampshire's
electoral system secure democracy
supports the bill and encourages all
members of the committee to support its
passage okay will you be taking
questions from the committee I hope I'll
be able to answer them okay well we'll
see if there are any
it doesn't appear so you get you you
answered every question that you were
asked wonderfully thank you all
um next up is Mark lindman from
if you could press that uh button there
there you go one more there you go I'm
live okay
um I have written testimony I'll
distribute it but I won't read it now
um uh I'm Mark Lindemann I'm policy and
strategy director at verified voting and
national uh non-partisan non-profit that
basically works at the intersection of
technology and elections to make sure
that technology is used appropriately
for Justified public confidence and
outcomes and some of you may know my
name from the Windham audit I was the
town of windham's Representative to that
audit team so I've spent a lot of
quality time with both state and local
election officials here in New Hampshire
and I really do feel like I have skin in
the game
I've also been working on routine
post-election audits like the one
proposed here since 2007. so
I know some stuff some of it may be
wrong to know what I want to emphasize
is that tabulation audits of the type
we're describing here to check the
accuracy of votabulations
ultimately always should refer back to
paper ballots they should not rely on
ballot images whether those ballot
images are captured by the original
voting machine as we were discussing yes
or captured by a secondary scanner such
as the clear ballot system we're
describing in this why is that well
plain and simple voters can verify their
own ballots voters have no way to verify
ballot images and in fact there is no
authoritative reason to trust digital
ballot images they are hardware and
software artifacts they can be erroneous
in any number of ways potentially they
could be subverted by malicious software
which could actually undetectably swap
votes in the images now I mean no I did
not come here today to tell you that I
think that's likely what I'm here to
tell you today is that you should take
that question off the table by having
the audit refer back to individual
ballots
so the way I would go about doing that
uh the ideal way first of all is when
the ballots are rescanned to imprint
them in the margins with a serial number
and then you can authoritatively link
each ballot to how the audit system
interpreted that ballot okay so uh
representative wary we're not really
talking about a hand count here exactly
we're talking about individual points of
comparison so in the bill as it comes to
you as I understand it the intention is
individual points of comparison between
the ballot images and how the audit
system interpreted those but since I
don't want to refer to the ballot images
I want to go back to the ballots I would
suggest uh randomly sampling 100 ballots
and seeing how the audit system
interpreted each of those
um you can use the fixed sample size no
matter how many ballots are rescanned
it's the same Principle as a national
public opinion poll of a thousand people
having the same margin of error whether
it's a national pool as I just said or
whether it's a up all of a mayoral
contest from the margin of error really
depends on the sample size right that's
the end and the N minus one all that
uh so
with that by limiting uh the check on
the system to a hundred paper ballots
first of all you're getting a more
trustworthy uh check
um second you're probably making
yourself some time to uh scan it and
audit a few more machines because that's
that sample does not have to increase
and you also have a system that is
adaptable to hand counts and uh to other
machines that they come online I agree
that this committee this legislature
will be revisiting the audit statute but
I don't think you have to uh pass a
statute that's kind of used once and
throw away so I have other comments I'll
distribute them but those are my
highlights and I'm here if there are
questions
representative Meerhead just with
respect thank you Mr chairs that just
the respect to those other comments you
will be sending us
um
I I read the advice not to hand out the
the testimony because people will be
reading it instead of listening so I'm
try I'm working really hard to be
engaging here especially representative
mirror has known for that you have a
follow-up
I'm just looking just to note that I'm
looking forward to reading those I'm
sure you are
foreign
okay thank you
um last up is Liz Aya kabuchi did I get
that close
uh we need to know what town you're from
Miss Ian kabuchi
excellent what what town do you live in
make sure you press that silver button
in front of you there you go I
I'll have written testimony that I'll
pass out afterward
um basically I just wanted to say that
we are actually sensitive to the
challenges of trying to audit elections
here in the granite state you have lots
and lots of individual small
jurisdictions so it's a different
environment than in trying to audit in
other states
um but with that said we really do want
you to please include at least some
paper ballots as you're auditing you'll
see in my handout that images can be
hacked and as Mark said you don't want
to introduce that uncertainty into a
process that's intended to reassure
people about the validity of the
election results
um also I'm going to Echo the request to
eliminate the current references to
accuvote and to broaden the spectrum of
what's covered again you don't want to
throw away statute that's you're already
beginning to use non-aggy vote machines
um
I would also like to ask that you
include the presidential primary in your
scheme here we've been talking with
Federal uh yes we've been talking with
federal election security folks and they
are actually warning us that um the 2024
election is already a target of both
foreign and domestic interference and
first in the nation primary
New Hampshire has a responsibility to
produce
trustworthy results and so I strongly
recommend that you extend this I know
it's a short turnaround time but I
strongly recommend that you audit the
presidential primary last one is I will
ask you suggest that you increase the
number of town or city Wards that's the
language currently in the bill you've
got more than 300 polling places
234 municipalities if you're only
auditing four that's not going to give
folks very much confidence in the audit
results
and I'm happy to take questions
questions from the committee
representative you have a question
no okay uh no I think that's it
um representative what can you grab that
blue sheet for me um I don't have anyone
else signed up at least in pink cards
and then we are running a little bit
because we've already had lunch as you
know
okay
um there was one person signed up in
support of who did not speak uh and with
that I will close the
um public hearing on Senate Bill 158 I
will immediately open up the public
hearing on S B where is my list I think
it's 70 but I want to trust me
157 I meant I meant to close 157 I mean
to open 158 how about that
um we're opening up Senate Bill 158
thank you my name is James Gray I
represent Senate District Six which just
starts up in all gimmonton and goes down
Route 11 into Rochester
um absentee powder a ballot outer
envelopes
they're not needed except to put stamps
on and addresses on and we need to get
rid of them
if you go to the state of Maine they
have one envelope and they do their
affidavits and they do their mailing
addresses and they do all of that stuff
in one
uh
the people who have fought this uh
particular legislation the hardest are
the clerks saying that it's going to
cause them
amounts of time that they don't have
when it comes to election day
if a person comes in votes
and doesn't need to put it in an outer
envelope I kind of doubt that there's a
whole lot of extra time and it's going
to take them to look and make sure that
the affidavit is signed
that the ones that are coming in in the
mail
uh that if you mail one in
the clerks should be able to open that
outer envelope and then look at the
affidavits to make sure it's signed if
they were to wait until the last day
before the election whether it's you're
in Florida or wherever else there's not
the ability that would have been there
to cure
these same people are the ones that ask
us to do all the same things that we did
during covid when we allowed them to
open the auto envelopes on Saturday
Sunday or Monday before the election and
mark up the checklist
if you're going to do it then it should
be even easier to do if there's no outer
envelope involved in the first place uh
the the outer envelope doesn't do
anything right now the statute says that
you know you'll maintain it in the outer
envelope until election day and then the
moderator starts the process and the
absentee ballots he opens the outer
level openspects them for Signature Etc
uh since we brought up signature there
was Court decision that precludes Us in
New Hampshire from comparing signatures
on the application with the signature on
the affidavit
but that decision had two things in it
it said that
you would be able to compare the
signatures if there were a way to cure
in other words fix a mistake they didn't
sign it they printed instead of signing
they did whatever and the other thing
that they wanted is that the people who
were comparing the signature be trained
um certainly the Secretary of State's
office has told me several times that
they would provide the training
and the last part is the ability to cure
if they they're not in the outer
envelope
certainly the clerks will be able to to
at least look at the signatures to make
sure it is signed
and make sure that it says John James
instead of Jane Doe that would be
another reason that we right now we
could reject it if it was the wrong name
but with some of those signatures you
can't tell one squiggly line from
another squiggly line because a lot of
our our students aren't taught in in
school anymore to uh to actually sign
anything they're taught how to make the
first initial I'm told and then a
squiggle after that that kind of looks
like something but again
the purpose of this is to to take away
work from the clerks to take away work
from the others right now like I say
that if
you for some reason uh stuck at your
ballot in an envelope it would not be
noticed until election day and there'd
be no way for you to be notified to come
back on Election Day so this would would
do that would give the ability to cure
and the only other thing that's really
missing from this uh that they had
during the covid when they were doing
the bounce is that they were allowed at
that point to uh to actually highlight
sections of the checklist there's
nothing in state law right now that says
they couldn't highlight the checklist
the only things they would not be
allowed to do and they were not allowed
to do it during covid is put the red AV
next to their name because that in state
law says that they have already voted
and you would not be able to accept
ballot if they came in and voted in
person which they are allowed to do
especially during those first two hours
when we we say you can't process your
absentee balance until after that but if
you haven't processed it by the time
somebody comes in
and they decide they wanted to vote in
person that is perfectly in fact it's
the preferred thing to do but I'll be
quiet and hopefully we'll get to onto
the next bill and I can get out and back
to my committee can only be so lucky are
there questions from the committee
all right see look at that if you
preface it with don't ask me questions
next up is Nash graze from Concord New
Hampshire with the New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair and it's crazy with
the municipal Association we do support
Senate bill 158. it provides greater
flexibility in processing absentee
ballots and we believe makes the process
somewhat simpler
because it eliminates the need to place
absentee ballots a return to the clerk
in person in the outer Envelope as well
as allows pre-processing of
um
AKA opening the outer envelopes for
those that are actually mailed and this
is something that our members have asked
uh us to support and we are supporting
happy to take any questions the
committee may have questions from the
committee
all right we're trying to get cloud back
up thank you Nate thank you
Mr Graves I should say a little more
formal uh last up Susan paschell from
Concord New Hampshire with secure
democracy
hi again and thank you Susan paschell
from the DuPont group here for secure
democracy I'll just read part of my
written statement so I'll even be
quicker than two minutes that is that to
Echo what Senator gray said uh this will
cut down on work for Clarks because
during the 2020 presidential election 31
percent of total votes cast in New
Hampshire were cast through an absentee
ballot over 250 000 voters equates to a
significant amount of administrative
electoral work for Town and City Clerks
particularly in smaller localities that
may only have a small staff and
volunteer pool
Senate Bill 158 is a practical and
fiscally responsible method to make
processing absentee bad balance faster
and more efficient we strongly urge you
to pass this bill
okay will you be taking questions I will
I will try Okay are there any questions
from the committee
and there you go you did it uh I don't
have anyone else sign up to speak uh
representative gray I almost called you
I mean gray representative wood
um if you could grab that uh blue sheet
almost back on time thank you all right
uh there were two people uh signed up in
favor who did not speak uh and with that
I will close the public hearing on SB
158 the committee will stand in recess
for about four minutes until uh 2 30
foreign
okay it's 2 30.
um I'm going to open the
house election Law Public hearing on
scr1
um I believe uh Mr bossy is pinch
hitting for Senator Bert cell
I can I can assure you we'd all rather
have Senator Bert cell as would I uh she
she's currently in the finance committee
considering the many changes uh you
folks have made to hb1 and hb2 and
thanks you for the courtesy good
afternoon chairman Barry members of the
election along committee I am Grant
bossy
from the New Hampshire Senate here to
introduce scr1 not only on behalf of
Senator Regina Birdsall the prime
sponsor but also the 23 other Senators
who co-sponsored this resolution
uh since 1916 New Hampshire has chosen
its delegates to the Republican and
Democratic national conventions through
our primary since 1975 state law has
mandated that New Hampshire's primary be
held at least a week before any similar
contest
the New Hampshire primary is important
for several reasons and not just for the
health of our state New Hampshire voters
expect candidates to earn their votes
Grassroots campaigns Force candidates to
persuade voters making them better
candidates and better prepared to serve
as president
winning in New Hampshire or having a
surprisingly good showing can help
candidates secure their party's
nomination but a poor showing in New
Hampshire can end a struggling campaign
narrowing the field for upcoming
contests
the current challenge of the first in
the nation primary isn't from Delaware
or Nevada or Arizona but from Washington
D.C
while the Republican National Committee
has confirmed New Hampshire's status the
Democratic National Committee wants to
move other states in front of us and
threatens not to seat New Hampshire
delegates if we stay first in compliance
with our state law
the DNC even sent you a list of Demands
on how we should amend our state
election laws to suit them you will
decide how our elections are run and how
the delegates are chosen Senator
Birdsall urges you to send a signal to
Washington that we stand United in
support of New Hampshire's first in the
nation primary she thanks you for your
consideration and support of scr1 thank
you
okay I assume you won't take any
questions you're not a sinner uh if you
have questions I can get them to a
senator and make sure you get answers I
have questions
um no
um see if I have anything they want to
submit to submit to the Senate to ask
questions for I didn't think so uh thank
you uh Mr bossy it's always good for me
I don't know him and I have a very good
relationship so it's uh we could be
tongue-in-cheek with each other it's
okay
um is there anyone else who wishes to
speak to scr1 I thought that one would
have gotten a little more uh love on the
calendar but I guess not
um nobody wants to come up here and
defend our first the nation primary no
no no no lobbyists want to do that uh
awesome okay uh with that I will close
the hearing on scr1 and we will
reconvene in 35 25 minutes at three
three o'clock oh yeah let's grab that
blue hey um representative boy can
collecting my
binders appear like my clipboards and
just like all the clipboards all the
clipboards okay uh yes if you could uh
and there were two people signed in in
favor who did not speak
um so all right one last chance you
might want to get up here and if in this
primary all right no okay
um I'm gonna close the public hearing on
foreign
okay I hope everybody enjoyed the break
I'm going to open back up the house
lecture Law Public hearings going to
open the public hearing on sb70
um before we recognize Senator gray
there are quite a few people
um signed up to speak on this
um so I am going to enforce a time limit
I think there's well over a dozen
um so we are going to limit testimony to
three minutes peace including Senator
gray a previous request of the ranking
member who's not here is that that
applies to everybody so unfortunately I
have to apply that to you but don't be
mad at me be mad at the person who's not
here it's way easier to blame her
thank you I'm ready
um my name is James Gray I'm a senator
from District Six which starts up in
Alton goingson goes down Route 11 to
Rochester uh this bill has back again
um
the interpretation of what was written
before
had a lot more computer work in there
what's envisioned is that a person will
be able to go to the portal they'll be
able to request a name change and
address change a
whatever else party affiliation change
Etc and then that information through
election net or its successor will be
transferred to the uh Clerk or the
supervisor of the checklist and they
will be able to assist you in in
accomplishing that certainly the vision
for the future is that if you're
standing there in line uh waiting to
register
that in some distant distant you know
not even thought of yet that you'd be
able to electronically fill out the form
hit a button when you get up there you'd
say oh I just sent this and it gave me
this number one two three four five six
and the person say yep yep all I need to
do is see your license and we're good to
go and but we're not there yet so we're
going to start with baby steps get the
portal out there let the people
especially all of us who are now you
know live by our phones be able to to do
some of this information and I think I'm
within the time limit Mr chair you
managed to do it uh we timeline doesn't
apply to questions um so anybody who
wants to ask a question may ask a
question just those open call the
opening Salvo
all right you get off that easy thank
you Cinder gray I don't believe we have
any more of you today right um well are
you coming back there is an amendment
yes I'm not really in favor of it okay I
might stay around for it all right you
gotta do what you got to do
um next up on the list is Linda Bundy
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
house election law
I'm Linda Bundy and I'm from Antrim I
support sb70 and election information
portal and will provide others with
voters with increased accessibility to
the registration process and updating of
information
residents of Rural and low socioeconomic
communities as well as individuals with
medical conditions or physical
disabilities face specific challenges to
registration
being able to submit an application
electronically at their own convenience
mitigates those obstacles
making it easier to register before
election day can reduce long lines and
waiting at the polls I have worked at
the past three elections as a ballot
Clerk and I can see the benefits of the
portal based on my experience
and election information portal will
increase the efficiency of the work of
the supervisors of the checklists
elimination of a physical paper document
will reduce errors due to handwriting
data entry or missing information and
remove the additional step of having to
spend time inputting information into
the system
the local municipal clerk will still
verify that the information provided is
accurate and meets all requirements
prior to registration
the reduction in printing mailing and
staff time will reduce costs for the
local municipality
many members of the public who testified
before the special committee on voter
confidence cited the importance of
modernizing our elections and in its
final report the committee said there is
a need to have updated checklist
verification an election information
portal would be an important improvement
in our elections that will increase
accessibility and accuracy while
maintaining security and integrity
now is the right time to make the
sensible step forward of establishing an
election information portal I ask that
the committee vote ought to pass on SB
70. thank you for your time will you be
taking questions Miss Bundy
no thank you okay next up is uh Beverly
good afternoon chairman Berry committee
members thank you so much for your time
today uh I too am in support of sb70 uh
I am very pleased to see this portal
making its way through our legislator
this Tuesday it's going to allow uh for
creation of a new voter application uh
requesting an absentee ballot an
updating of demographic information
the portal will also allow our voter
roles to remain current with up-to-date
information and allow for less of a
burden on our town clerks I am a ballot
Clerk and have been for several years
and I am witness to the great deal of
lines
um at the polls to provide updated
information this allows that to be done
ahead of time but does not sacrifice the
requirement of any form of identity
confirmation so we are not
um
compromising that integrity
today 40 States in Washington DC use
portals they describe a significant
reduction in omitted information and
paper forms
New Hampshire spends 1.5 million dollars
to 4 million dollars depending on the
election year to process paper forms
this bill is a common sense step towards
making our elections more efficient we
should be working to make voting as
accessible as possible for voters to
have their turn in participation in
their democracy and this moves the ball
forward a bit
it's still
um it's a modest cost it's under a half
million dollars uh nationally it's
reported between 250 000 and 600
thousand dollars is the cost to
implement the portal and we're right
about in the middle of that so
um we seem to be in in a better place
than last year's estimate the municipal
Savings of a large portion of the 10
million dollars in paper processing that
we've spent since 2014 seems to be
making that a very well investment
a significant uh relief
to
election officials it is a significant
Improvement in data Integrity of our
voter rolls so I would strongly urge you
to support this
ought to pass
sb70 and I have some if your data Geeks
I have some data here for you that I
will pass around thank you so much for
your time today
awesome will you be taking questions
from the committee I will are there
questions from the committee
okay and if you want to give what you
have to representative wood I try to
avoid the pass around while we're in
testimony of respect for others but I'm
sure representative wood will distribute
it after we're done hearing from
everybody and
got the Angry Birds going
um
let's all let's all look at him and and
next up is going to be Louise Spencer if
you want to get on Deck well
representative
[Music]
um
uh yep sorry uh there you go everybody
good job for present foam I don't think
uh I don't think we went in any races on
that anytime soon
um all right I've never been invited up
to speak with well if you think about it
it's two musics it's kind of like entry
music like on WWE you know when the
wrestlers come out like that was for you
yes all right we're ready to go when you
are sure thank you so my name is Louise
Spencer and I um and I live in Concord
and uh I am the co-founder of the Kent
Street Coalition which is an
all-volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization and I thank you Mr chair
and committee members for taking my
testimony today
um I am here on behalf of Ken Street
urging the committee to vote ought to
pass on SB 70. this bill would have the
benefits of
um significantly reducing mistakes in
the registration process and then
process to update our roles voting rules
holes and would increase efficiency
while still honoring the New Hampshire
tradition the valued tradition of having
local officials be the final
determinants of who's qualified to vote
I think that's a really important aspect
of this
I just want to say that my husband now
retired is a physician and
his handwriting is terrible really awful
and in the early days all the
prescriptions were handwritten and as
electronic medical records were
developed those got transferred into an
electronic format
Studies have shown that there have been
up to 35 40 percent reduction in errors
for prescriptions since the adoption of
electronic medical records so if you saw
my husband's handwriting you would
understand how that is a possible
statistic so
um I've also attended a good number of
Supervisors of the checklist meetings
and have seen where they've had to hold
up and pass around a registration to
determine is that a j or a k or is this
named Maria or Marin
and oftentimes also having to go back
into
electionnet to update information that's
already there and what is a very time
consuming process so if people are
entering their own information correctly
that will greatly reduce errors and so
is another reason why I believe that
this this is a very strong bill that
gives us time to see you know it's a
step forward as Senator gray said and
and so for that reason I urge out to
pass okay will you be taking questions
from the committee sure another
questions from the committee all right
easy enough thank you thanks so much
next up Sue
it wasn't even close all right from
all right well thank you uh chair Ross
Berry the election law committee and
Senator gray for being the prime sponsor
of the bill SB 70. as a voter learning
of sb70 and what the bill would do if it
became law my my reaction is yes what a
great idea to be able to adjust a home
or a domicile or a mailing address
or a party affiliation plus request an
absentee ballot
a new neighbor with hours difficult to
go to town hall can start the voter
application online
again as a voter and and they'll retired
I always have to check what are the
current Town Hall hours
of course you realize that during covid
and the ease of guidelines hours kept
changing at different town halls
but you know at least parking is always
easy in Rollinsford
but a nearby Dover can be limited
second I'm one of the three supervisors
of the checklist for Rollinsford love
the job the work involved and I look at
the duties to service the voters on an
election day plus keeping the towns
checklist of Voters accurate throughout
the year as rewarding
staying current with policies and
whatever changes we are told by Trisha
of the Secretary of State's office we
learn adjust and know as part of the
supervisor's job
earlier in my work life I've serve as
the public maybe in retail or a medical
practice
and it's a good advantage to you know be
used to
servicing the public being able to speak
to the public and I also looked at as
being
can be lapped over even to be
nonpartisan
as a supervisor
I see advantage to SB 70. a new voter or
a voter change in an address or changing
their last name there is flexibility and
ease for the voter Plus for supervisors
reading penmanship
has been a challenge
time has been used to make Corrections
due to a spelling error which then
causes a combining of files Within
electionnet for example there can be a
file of Jack and another file of jock
and then learn it's the same voter
so this is like a combining deleting
files and
can be interesting
um
third as illegal mem voters member I
support sb70.
an election information portal supports
voter registration which supports voters
casting their ballot on Election Day
this increases flexibility and ease for
voting and also an encouragement to vote
the league is nonpartisan and the lead
educates the public on a nonpartisan
basis
the more voters are informed and with
knowledge that they have adjusted online
their status all the better on Election
Day
happy please voter excellent you nailed
are you um we're at the end of your time
I don't want to completely cut you off
so if you have any let's call it um
closing shots
thank you for your time that's an
excellent one
does anybody will you be taking
questions sure are there any questions
from the committee
okay thank you thank you
uh next up uh the other league Women
Voters uh lee Liz tantarelli from
thank you for this opportunity to speak
to this bill I've been doing this oh
sorry Liz tantarelli president of the
League of Women Voters of New Hampshire
and I've been testifying on in favor of
this bill for the last three years when
Senator gray first introduced it in his
committee I publicly stated you're my
new BFF
to my eternal embarrassment since then
but you know I'm glad that I've lived
long enough to be in the 21st century
and this bill brings voting rights into
the 21st century
my written testimony references two
reports one by the Brennan Center one by
the legal defense fund that this kind of
information portal will in the long run
save money and the ballot clerks and
supervisors who have testified have
indicated that already
at last count that I could find there
are only eight states that don't do some
form of online voter registration so
it's about time we join the rest of the
country
when we talk to younger people about
voting they sometimes look at me very
peculiar peculiarly when I say you have
to do this at your town clerk's office
like why should they do that the rest of
their lives are online why would they do
that and people scoff when I say go to
your town clerk's office and they say
they're open eight minutes a week now I
realize that's an exaggeration
but it does indicate that for some
voters it's just not convenient to
register that way to go there and do a
simple change of address and so on
so it is for those reasons that I
strongly support this bill it will help
us in our work to empower voters and I
urge you to support it I will take
questions if there are any are there any
questions from the committee you
preempted me all right thank you next up
nature Grays with the from Concord New
Hampshire with the New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair and each Graves for
the municipal Association we also
support this bill uh we love bills that
try to make voting processes simpler and
more efficient I think the rest of my
testimony would be repetitive of what
you've already heard so I'm happy to
take any questions if committee has some
okay let's see everybody take notes this
is how I know
um doesn't have any questions for the
committee
all right well that was easy thank you
next up Susan paschell from Concord New
Hampshire with secure democracy
going once going twice oh they're there
I'm sorry I didn't see you sit down I
apologize you stuck in
I was looking over here you already made
it all right thank you thank you Mr
chair members of the committee again
Susan paschell from the DuPont group in
Concord and we represent secure
democracy and we strongly support this
bill I won't repeat all the points
you've heard before but I'll just cover
a few creating this information portal
will help voters in local election
administrators as you've heard at its
core the online information portal
simply permits eligible residents to
fill out and submit an application
electronically it'll improve election
Integrity by helping New Hampshire keep
more accurate voting roles being able to
submit applications online would
increase accuracy of the voter checklist
because it becomes more convenient for a
voter to update so we see it as a
practical step forward for New
Hampshire's electoral system and we hope
you will vote up to pass thanks for your
consideration will you be taking
questions no okay that's easy enough all
right next up is Sarah Lobdell from
uh good afternoon thank you for taking
my testimony I'll hand around copies
afterward
um my name is Sarah Lobdell I'm a voter
and poll worker in Keene and program
coordinator of open democracy we're a
non-partisan non-profit representing 36
000 voters across New Hampshire
um and we are urging on to pass on sb70
most of what is in my testimony is
already said but I would just highlight
two things one is that this portal would
make it easier for voters to register if
they can't get to their clerk when it's
open eight minutes a week such as people
who work people who might be going to
school full-time people who just can't
get out of their house for various
reasons so this would really be very
much helpful for these voters
and second of all as a as a poll worker
last election I worked the checklist
addendum table and that's where people
who register same day come and you put
them on the checklist and I would say a
vast majority of the folks that we saw
were either simply changing an address
from like one number to the next or new
voters who were younger and more likely
to access and use such a portal as this
and for people simply changing an
address or name this would make it a
whole lot easier so
urging out pass on sb70 and happy to
take any questions are there questions
from the committee
okay thank you very much thank you next
okay from Franklin New Hampshire we're
committee and my name is Olivia Zink
executive director of open democracy
action and nonpartisan nonprofit I live
in Franklin and I also have testimony
from Judith Ackerson who is the ward 3
supervisor of the checklist in Franklin
New Hampshire so I'll quickly cover both
things I want to thank this committee
for all the work that you have done to
modernize applications the application
process voter registration forms and and
it's really important that we begin to
modernize elections last year I had the
privilege and honor to serve on the
voter confidence committee and I spent
37 hours traveling around or 37 hours of
meetings traveling around the state
listening to voters and many believed
that having clean checklists would
increase confidence in our election
process and modernization would also
create voter confidence it's an
important step in supporting local poll
workers
I serve as a selectman or city councilor
in my community and so I have a role on
Election Day and I just want to tell one
story a voter came to check in and their
name was not on the checklist when they
handed me their ID
lo and behold they did register to vote
but their last name was spelled
incorrectly on the checklist their last
name the second letter was an O instead
of an a I was lucky to flip the page and
just double check like maybe it got
misspelled because they swore they were
already registered and I think that this
um
portal will help make these Corrections
so that accurate names are on a voter
checklist
Judith uh ward 3 supervisor of the
checklist says she was elected to A
system that is is Antiquated we need to
This Crew the current system of paper
forms creates a lot of work for
supervisors of the checklist and she has
no hesitancy in modernizes modernizing
Judith wanted to point out that this is
a bipartisan bill that has support from
both parties and that we need
legislation with bipartisan support
and that this will continue to keep our
election system safe while we modernize
election volunteers and especially
supervisors of the checklist give an
enormous hours for training for showing
up at town halls for the re for meetings
and their polling places and um Judith
hopes that this system can pass to make
a more efficient in the duties for her
supervisor at the checklist and with
that I'm happy to take any questions
thank you questions from the committee
this is okay all right this very unusual
all right next up Jordan Applewhite from
Sugar Hill New Hampshire
I'm sorry I didn't get you in there
earlier I should have I didn't realize
you were in the bottom I should have
moved it Forward I'll try to do the
non-lobbyists up front and apologize
uh make sure you hit that that button in
front of you right there like that okay
absolutely uh hello my name is Jordan
Applewhite I'm a supervisor of the
checklist in Sugar Hill and I'm here
today to testify in sport of sb70 I
lived in three other states before
making New Hampshire my home and all
three of those States enjoy the modern
conveniences laid out in this bill
when I moved here I was surprised to
discover that registering to vote
required visiting my town clerk at an
office it's only open for 10 hours a
week in the middle of the work day
opponents of sb70 may say even if
registering at the town clerk's office
is inconvenient why not just register on
Election Day
for starters not everyone has the
privilege to take off work so they can
vote workers with a long commute can't
simply pop over to town building on
their lunch break
also I'm sure most of their supervisors
and election officials would agree that
we prefer to minimize the number of
same-day registrations
not only does it create a bottleneck at
our table when we receive an influx of
new applicants all at once but perfectly
eligible voters often bring inadequate
documentation to verify their Identity
or domicile
in these cases we resort to the use of
Legally binding affidavits to make sure
our residents are not disenfranchised
Justice session however we saw some of
the legislature fighting to remove this
affidavit system that allowed 3 500
eligible Granite Staters to vote last
fall
in light of ongoing efforts to make
same-day registration more difficult
it's only prudent to allow convenient
options for registering and fixing
problems ahead of election day
sb70 is a needed step in that direction
ultimately there are two increasingly
polarized points of view when it comes
to election reform one says that despite
no evidence of fraud we must tighten and
restrict our voting systems it alleges
wrongdoing among the hard-working
volunteers who spend long days clerking
and filing and counting to make sure our
Democratic exercise is possible
myself and the other election officials
of all political Persuasions who I'm
proud to call my friends we feel
differently we believe our democracy is
most secure when every eligible voice is
heard when every voter feels that their
contribution is honored sb70 might just
look like a common sense modernization
of a few paper forms but it's also a
show of respect and understanding to
working Granite Staters it takes nothing
away from those who prefer to register
and vote in person but for some sb70
will make the difference between whether
they're able to vote at all thanks very
much
will you be taking questions uh no
thanks all right that's fine next up is
Matt mushin from Claremont New Hampshire
and I'm sure I just butchered your name
I apologize
oh
nailed it nailed it
thank you very much uh I will also keep
it short because much of my testimony
you've already heard
um but my name is Matt musian I live in
Claremont where I serve as a city
councilor and today I'm here
representing 603 Ford
non-partisan non-profit organization
dedicated to educating activating and
empowering young people in New Hampshire
and we support Senate Bill 70 for the
reasons you've heard today because we
believe that by allowing voters to
easily and safely access an online
election information portal for their
voting needs folks will be more likely
to register before election day and
it'll in turn help reduce lines or
potential confusion at the polls which
as you heard will help granted State
voters and our hard-working election
officials
and ultimately by providing photos with
accessible and up-to-date information
about the voting process it'll make it
easier for young working age people in
New Hampshire to exercise the right to
vote so we are due to vote ought to pass
on this bill and I would take any
questions you have all right other
questions from the committee
they are quiet all right last up is
Kelsey DeVille from Lincoln
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Kelsey DeVille
um I am from Lincoln Massachusetts but
it's a point of Pride to say that I was
born and raised in Auburn New Hampshire
and I'm a newly minted Massachusetts
resident and but so I am the election
official program manager with the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights
which is a non-partisan coalition of
organizations working in support of
voting rights and healthy democracy and
is a project of America votes New
Hampshire I'm here today in support of
sb70
establishing an election information
portal would benefit both our election
officials as we've heard a lot about
today and voters by allowing voters to
complete a new voter application request
an absentee ballot or make updates to
their registration quickly and easily
online many people are already
comfortable handling their banking their
bill payments and car registrations
online and a safe and secure way and
it's a common sense decision to give
voters that same option for their voter
registration
with the ease of completing a voter
application or updating their info
through a portal we can also reduce the
number of Voters registering for the
first time on Election Day which can
lead to long lines at many polling
places especially during presidential
elections
voters would also be able to immediately
update their address upon moving helping
to keep the voter voter rolls updated
and accurate something we know can
increase voter competence
an election information portal will also
support our supervisors of the checklist
cutting back on the amount of data entry
and difficulty of reading handwriting
again reducing potential errors with
this legislation voter registration
applications will go to local election
officials to be processed meaning they
still have oversight and are at the
heart of the registration process
we've been very glad to hear that the
Secretary of State mentioned an updated
election net system would be compatible
with the potential election information
portal
with 42 States in Washington DC
utilizing online systems now is the time
for New Hampshire to utilize this
upgrade and create an election
information portal that works with our
elections I thank you for your time I
will say our campaign director Mackenzie
St Germain is out of town and is usually
here testifying so if you have questions
I would urge you to direct them to her
and I will not be taking questions
awesome would anyone else like to speak
to this bill sb70 uh representative wood
so now we'll see when you set the limit
you're fast okay
um
there was there was one person signed in
not speaking and they were signed up in
favor with that I'm willing to close the
um uh public hearing on sb70 and I'm
going to open the public hearing on my
own non-germain Amendment and hand the
invisible gavel over to the vice
chairman and realize I did not pass out
my Amendment so I'm going to do the
thing that I hate the most which is
distribute paperwork in the middle of my
own testimony
foreign
and then I'm gonna go sit up front
okay
all right
like that
um and a note to the vice chair um when
we are over with this uh please do not
close the public hearing entirely I just
have one more announcement I have to
make so don't just close it up and
gavel us out
perfectly invisible gavel
there you go that should be everybody
all right
okay
a hearing for amendment to sb70 and
and I recognize
representative Ross Berry who written
input
uh thank you
um fellow committee members I'm here to
introduce house Amendment 2023 1280h
which is amendment to sb70 uh it does
two things it takes uh deals with the
bill we just heard
um about the election not portal and it
takes the um bill regarding the Hava
money um for which bill it was um but
the bill that where we would fund half
of the machine purchase with the Hava
money it takes that bill and attaches it
to the bottom of hb70 and then changes
one thing about hb70 which is right now
HP 7 sb70 excuse me sb70 draws I believe
from the general fund this would change
the funding mechanism to for sb70 to the
Haba funds so a couple reasons uh why I
did that
um so when we were hearing the
information about the machine bill
um I've never seen the Hava money table
before I think you guys probably all
remember that holla money table
um and I looked at the Hava money table
and I understood the Secretary of
State's concerns with not drawing those
funds down
um I didn't uh Express those concerns at
the time especially from the chair
because that would be inappropriate but
the way the money is being managed the
argument of protecting the fund is kind
of moot with me
um the money is already not being
protected in that if there was if the
state was acting as a proper fiduciary
on the Hava money they would be taking
the interest earned backfilling it into
the principal to offset inflation and
then spending whatever was left right so
in a regular year we'd see three percent
inflation right if they got a seven
percent return on the money they take
the three percent they'd shove it back
in and they spend the four percent which
is not nothing four percent of 12
million dollar
um that would that interest would end up
being several hundreds of thousands of
dollars that we could spend on
effectively anything related to to
helping people vote and it would
continue to grow so we'd have that same
value modern day value going forward the
state's not doing that they're not
getting that
um I I'm kind of like baffled how the
state's not getting that just for
reference over the last 30 years the S P
500 has averaged a 9.88 interest rate
return on investment so the fact that I
think we're kidding like less than six
or something and then spending it so
we're not we're not investing it back
into the principal we're just spending
the money so every year while we're
spending the same amount of money in
principle we're actually spending less
because inflation it's not a political
statement about inflation inflation
exists every single year regardless of
who's in the White House regardless of
who controls Congress it averages about
three percent a year so once I kind of
looked at that and realized all right
the argument about
um protecting this fund is moot because
you're already not protecting this fund
uh it then said all right well how can
we actually get what we want so we know
that our College on the other side of
the wall I really love the portal we
probably want the Hava money is being
spent on the machines and I said well
here's a great opportunity to marry the
two and get we can have our cake and eat
it too
so it's that's what the build does I'm
happy to answer any questions we've
already heard testimony on both bills I
rolled them I rolled the my own
Amendment non-germaine just so nobody
could say that I didn't but I actually
probably could have just
administered this because we've already
had a hearing on the bill that it is
based off of so I'm happy to answer any
questions I'm sure I've missed something
in my testimony but I'm happy to answer
any questions and I'm sure they're
any questions in the committee
representative
thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking the question
um this committee has heard a bill that
talks about your what you have in your
Amendment which was each B 447 I believe
correct and I'm pretty sure this
committee retained that bill and I'm
wondering if as chair you might consider
you know creating a subcommittee to
bring that bill back and look at
details in that bill as opposed to
applying this amendment to a bill that
is largely unrelated yeah
um so the Senate's already killed the
Hava money the for the machines they
already did it so if you want a position
to negotiate you have to bring something
to the table if you catch my drift
so we can form all the subcommittees we
want
when you go to the table you got to get
something
um I will say uh and this was actually
announced what I was going to make
um at the end of it um uh represent a
ranking member Lane and I co-signed a
letter to the about law commission I'm
happy to make copy of the letters
available
um about to the backlog commission
basically saying like hurry it up so if
they do hurry it up we need this now
any further questions yeah
follow-up thank you
um given that this Senate has already
killed the Java funds bill
if this committee were to adopt this
amendment to SV 70 would it not make it
more difficult to pass the election
um overall so historically this body has
killed the portal bill so this is you
get something you want and we get
something we want historically we
obviously have not voted on the portal
Bill we won't until later but
historically it has gone down because
it's a million dollar website by the way
another reason I want to go into the
Hava money is I get these distinct
feeling that if the secretary of state
is controlling it with Hava money then
it won't be a million dollar website if
you were you weren't uh for those of you
who are around last year it was a four
million dollar website last year so the
price has come down 75 percent in a year
which is impressive but I somehow get
the feeling that if there's a little
more oversight not an open warrant that
it won't be a million dollar boondoggle
and you won't have to hear that word
from me anymore it'll be a more
reasonable maybe thirty thousand dollar
boondoggle
which is probably what it should
actually cost but neither here nor there
million dollar website's insane may I
ask another fellow
um I don't have the amendment in front
of me so I can't look at the details of
what you have in the amendment
um but from what I gather there's a
grant program in the amendment is that
what you're proposing a grant program
for municipalities to receive Hava funds
for uh election counting machines
correct it's that program yeah it's the
Java it's the Java program money Bill I
forget the number you know I don't I
can't remember Bill numbers I can't
remember when I'm there in front of me
um but it's the Java it's the Hava bill
money the Hava money Bill that we heard
um
shoved shoved onto the back of sb70 and
then changing the funding mechanism for
sp70.
which by the way sb70 probably should be
funded with Hava money anyways just in
general it should be funded with other
it's literally about helping people vote
if in your Amendment does this allow for
municipalities to purchase the ballot
counting machines that they would all
counting machines they would need to run
their elections efficiently with new
machines correct it's the language is
identical it didn't change the word of
the actu of the of the machine part of
the language it went right on I told us
I told all us take it verbatim put it in
and change the funding mechanism for the
whole bill which included sb70 to have a
money
so one small change to sp70 and then
something that I think that the house
thank you thank you any other questions
yeah all right I'm gonna go hang out in
Senator Gray
they have my mic on thank you uh my name
is James Gray I represent Senate
District Six which starts up in Gilman
and Alton down Route 11 to Rochester
um I oppose the amendment uh
certainly the Senate has taken a
position
on using Java funds for this
a lot of people don't know that I'm also
a city councilman in Rochester and
certainly I'm not speaking for the city
council for Rochester but for myself
that if you're going to give me money
don't give me it with strings attached
to it give me the cash and I'll decide
whether I need to fix potholes or
whether I need additional funds for the
school whether I need to buy voting
machines or poll books or other devices
certainly the reason that you still have
Java funds is that the section law that
is being modified
and
requires that right now that we retain a
certain amount of that Java money I
think it's 12 times the annual cost
for for this purpose and
the money that we got in 2002 I believe
it was we have received additional money
throughout the years so that they have
been able to maintain that uh that 12
000 or 12 times the annual cost what is
it spent for now it's spent for the
training it's spent for uh upgrades in
the system that we use for accessible
voting
many of you if you're as old as I am
we've actually had three accessible
voting machines or revisions to the
accessible voting machines in the last
20 years
which is significant because we have
included more and more and more voters
in the ability to vote
at the polls on a regular ballot now a
ballot that goes into the accounting
devices it is a fallacy to think that if
we take the money and spend the Hava
money on something else because all of
that money that you're doing now I would
then have to come out of the general
fund so you know we don't create money
we don't destroy money
um you know we we tax people
so to think that you know if I say well
I'm going to go spend this money on
these devices that it's going to save
the people it's just going to come out
of a different pocket
why you know don't I want to spend the
money on the voting machines well I I
don't want a community out there that
says well gee
I just bought new voting machines two
years ago five years ago six years ago
and now because I don't like them or the
the new machines are out there and gee
it does this and that'll be so much
better you know hey if you want to go
buy new machines buy new machines spend
your money okay spend your tax dollars
the ones that you collected through
property tax or whatever
uh but you know leave the general fund
alone let the general fund you know when
the Secretary of State presented this
budget and it was at two o'clock to the
Senate finance committee I was
unfortunately over here instead of just
chairing that committee at the time but
they are going to come and they are
going to say I no longer have the Java
money if we're going to do these
pre-election trainings like we do every
year and if I'm going to do the election
manual which if they do every two years
if I am going to do all of these other
things including the accessible voting
machines that it's either got to come
out of Hava funds which it does now
because the funds are there and haven't
been touched or it's got to come out of
General funds so
you know I would rather it be the way
the system is right now I would rather
the communities
if they want to use a a voting machine
or a poll book they're certainly able to
Rochester decided to use poll books and
and does fund that and I'm sure that the
money that we've set aside for replacing
the voting machines as soon as there's
one approved that they believe is going
to be the useful one that we will go out
and do that so I'll let the communities
decide whether they're going to count by
hand count by uh you know machine use
pull books not use poll books let them
make that decision and they would fund
their own on that decision
but glad to take any questions any
questions
remember that I'm Howard
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Senator gray for taking my question uh
how many municipalities have purchased
um if you understand the history of the
accuvote machines
there haven't been any new machines
really purchased
LHS along with some of the other
companies have actually gone out to
other communities that have had the
accuvote machine or there was a similar
machine
that has a lot of replacement parts that
are used in the Accu votes and those are
the parts that are out there that
they're using to maintain machines they
include rollers they include include the
the motors in there even the Reed heads
and different things the guts of the
machine though the counting devices the
chips that are in there are all
dictated by the law commission so
except for some
New Old Stock or old new stock I forget
which way I'm supposed to say that uh
there there were some machines that that
you know they were able to purchase from
other communities but most likely they
were not accuvote machines they were the
sister machine that contained those uh
repair parts that have been serving the
follow up thank you uh so I guess uh to
rephrase it how much uh money have these
municipalities spent over the past
decade on their election processes
the communities including Rochester I
have a contract
and I believe the state is part of that
contract with LHS to maintain the
machines and to have them ready uh the
communities also can have the machines
serviced one of the things about the
Windham machines is that the window
machine that came from the school
district hadn't been serviced in a
number of years and contained a lot of
paper residue that's that was built up
in the machine which was a concern for
the Auditors because of that but you'd
have to go to the each individual
community
and because there's ballot counting in
there that could also skew your number
thank you
representative Brennan thank you thank
you for taking my question this
committee heard testimony from the
Secretary of State's office that the
Hava funds balance is in at least 12.9
million dollars and that purchasing
a new ballot counting machines would
be estimated to be around three million
dollars if every municipality were to
request a new machine as opposed to hand
counting which they may do can still
continue to do when those new machines
are online
um
would it be your testimony that the
municipalities should foot the bill for
the new machines
even with the excess of java funds that
are available to municipalities through
a grant program that would save
taxpayers dollars
well part of the reason that you do this
machine you know this is if you look in
the crossed out sections in here of what
the the current Java money is supposed
to do one of the things it's supposed to
do is maintain the system that we use
well part of that system is the
electionnet software right now the
secretary of state is in negotiation
with a company to replace the election
that software with something more modern
and I think that if you take that amount
of money and say I'm going to use that
for all the money I'm going to update
the portal you know from have a money
I'm going to use these machines from
ahava money I'm going to use the uh poll
books and I'm going to take that out of
Hava money uh very quickly that 12
million dollars that you talked about uh
is gone so again you're you're making a
choice for now or you're making the
choice so later uh the past legislatures
have decided that we would rather have
the Secretary of State have that money
to be able to do these different
trainings and upgrades for software Etc
as I mentioned earlier that we've had
actually three different accessible
voting machines in the last 20 years
that have been available
the last one the one we have now will
actually print on a regular ballot and
therefore will be able to be read buy
the accuvote machines the one
immediately prior to that had to be hand
counted because you used a blank sheet
of paper to put into the machine
and and get the ballot out so again it's
it's choices it's uh but if you are
short on any of that money and you've
depleted the uh have a money then the
secretary of state is going to have to
to come back through youth fiscal or
through other means and ask for money to
be transferred into or out of various
accounts
um I would just assume from what I know
being the vice chair fiscal and the
chair of Senate Finance I would rather
have the money available to them through
the Hava funds on hand so that he has it
and ready to spend to best help the
citizens of New Hampshire to be able to
vote
oh thank you
um
my understanding that with a grant
program
this amendment outlines that the
secretary of state would have to approve
the grant funds to municipalities which
would provide the secretary of state
with management of these funds to make
sure that
the Java funds are not depleted
um is am I misunderstanding this or do
you have a similar understanding of this
well you haven't defined in this
amendment you know all of the things
that are going to come out of there how
how people qualify for these grants how
how much you know
um how long it would be between one
Grant and the next Grant and you've also
got testimony of the author of the
amendment uh that he wants to make a
change to Senate Bill 70 so that the
portal funds would be paid for out of
the Hava money again you know if
the more you change this okay and make
it uh include things that the the Senate
has already voted on on other issues
um the less chance it has and you know
just as you've got the ability to put
this language you know into Senate Bill
70. I've got the option of putting
Senate Bill 70 on all kinds of things
that the house would like to get done uh
and you know playing tit for chat just
doesn't suit me well but you know I do
know how to play
thank you
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you Senator gray for taking my question
I was just wondering do you know how
much is spent from the Hava funds every
year uh no because the Secretary of
State as you look at the the crossed out
part of this bill says that he needs to
keep 12 times the annual maintenance
costs that he does in there and uh
uh that would get audited through you
know the Departments and presented to
fiscal but I haven't been on physical
long enough that that his Department
audit has come forward so okay I have
not looked thank you
any anybody else questions because I
have one now one of the things we've
heard
in our testimony on other things is that
the accuvoke machines the company that
makes them is no more no longer
servicing them they are not making Parts
you mentioned other places you can get
parts but not not through accuvote and
that's one of the reasons the
secretary of state is looking at and
other machines now if that's true which
I believe it is why then are we going to
force towns to spend money on machines
that they may only have spent five years
ago
some maybe 20 years ago but some maybe
just recently have bought an extra
machine and what they already paid for
now they're going to have to pay more
money because the second machines have
changed when we have the harbor money
the way I understand the contract with
the LHS is that they are guaranteeing
that the machines will be available
through the 2024 election cycle
um I don't know of any Community other
than
um you know buying
used machines from somewhere that has
actually spent any you know new money on
machines it has been a service of the
machines that are out there
certainly uh
if you look back in history the state of
New Hampshire has not bought any of
those machines as the community wants to
do the machine count then they have the
ability to do it and they have the uh
they would have the responsibility of
buying that machine
that if I I'm not forcing them to do it
I'm not forcing them not to do it
certainly I believe that there are
machines out there that we will find
satisfactory
and that in the next year and a half
I guess it's a little more than a year
and a half because it's uh the machines
would have to be ready for
a election the town elections in 2025
would be the time and if it were not
ready many of these towns
are not the the large towns that would
be needing to do this and by other towns
not needing as many machines it would
also leave more machines to be able to
to be used for the larger Towns now part
of this when we talk about the servicing
of the machines remember that the card
that goes in those machines also has to
be programmed and the current software
that's available for that is I think
it's Windows 95 which hasn't been
serviced for a long time that has
advantages and disadvantages nobody's
writing hacks to to go into those
machines anymore because nobody has them
okay and for the machines that we have
that are doing that are not connected to
the internet so there's good and bad
about it being and if you want to see
that you can go into the window audit
and where they talked about uh part of
the the reason that we week our
elections are secure as they are is
because the equipment is as old as it is
and that there's not a lot of people out
there that that would bother doing
anything with it
okay not seeing any more
questions uh thank you and I like to
call
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael O'Brien
um I put a support and a pose on the
card I come up here confused for the
second time today
um really just torn for the second time
today
um
America votes supports uh both these
bills individually
um and have supported both the portal
today and the use of hollow funds before
we
would love a deal to be reached where
both of these things could move forward
I will say the Secretary of State's
position
um when he uh from when they spoke here
um earlier to now seems to have softened
a little bit in front of house finance
they mentioned that they would be
willing to use a certain portion of
money to help Townsend the machines also
in a Globe article the secretary of
state was quoted as saying we know these
machines are on their last legs so
they're a little more forthright and
hope to have machines approved before
2024 if towns or cities want to use them
and so knowing the timeline
and that it is coming up again we it is
I think a good thing it would would be
good for the state to allow for
purchases to help at least to at least
help with some of the purchase of the
machine so that towns aren't stuck using
machines that may or may not work
however again uh we won't want it we
don't want to lose both by trying to
combine them together so
um if there's a deal can be reached
let's I would certainly encourage that
and love to see that but also recognize
that if that can't happen I wouldn't
don't want to lose both bills in an
effort that might not go there so that's
basically testimony and happy to take
any questions any questions
okay thank you
now our last speaker is nature
thank you Mr chair
um it appears there's there's a lot more
legislative negotiating here than I
recognized at first we do support this
amendment
um nature Grace for the municipal
Association sorry if I didn't say that
um as as identified by the committee
this is uh identical to House Bill 447
we testified in support of that bill
um as Mr O'Brien noted uh the security
State's office has spoken about the need
to replace the accuvote machine several
times since uh we heard that bill in
this committee and I'd also just like to
add for the committee's information
that uh if you haven't read the Concord
Monitor a few days ago David Brooks
reported that
um the three different machines uh three
different
three different types of machines were
used in three different town meetings
during the march Town meetings all
handled the ballots correctly there are
two more that are being tested in the
Maytown meetings so I anticipate that we
should expect the ballot law commission
to be able to make some kind of judgment
about what if any of those machines
should be certified and we could be on
the path to getting these uh very old
old machines the accuvote machines
replaced and that's really our focus is
try to have a smooth replacement smooth
roll out with as minimal cost as
possible to the local taxpayers I'm
happy to take any questions that the
committee may have
any questions
did you guys miss me uh representative
wood can we grab the uh
um
just so the committee knows uh I'm
probably going to schedule
the votes for everything that we did
today next Tuesday in the morning
um I have not come to that final
discussion you'll obviously know when I
schedule it um but that is my current um
what's called inclination
um so you know I I'm chair of two
committees nobody signed in to support
or against this uh and I'm closing the
public hearing on uh the not the
amendment 2023 1280 H uh sorry about
that um so everybody knows um I'm doing
that because I have my the child care
committee so I'm trying to front load
election law and backload child care
just to keep my life my life a little
easier
um I said I announced during my
testimony
um that
um ranking member Lane and I co-signed a
letter to the outlaw commission happy to
provide anyone copies with that who
would like to see it
um and with that I will probably see you
next week thank you guys so much I'm
going to close the our public hearing